hey guys this is Robin I want to take a
few seconds to appoint you guys in the
direction of a YouTube channel called
epic comic cast run by Tony Contreras
and his sister it's actually a really
cool really cool YouTube channel they
actually interviewed me a little while
ago and it was pretty exciting so if you
guys ever get a chance to definitely
check her channel out I think they do a
lot of unboxings and different things
like that it's just kind of fun so it's
just one of those well it's fun comic
book channels to check out so anyway
with that being said let's jump into the
review what's going on guys this is Rob
and it occurred to me recently that I've
never actually sat down and done a
full-on review that is to say sitting in
front of a camera talking directly with
you guys about the comics i've purchased
and you know which ones i enjoyed and so
on and so forth i think that doing this
is kind of a good idea you know because
it really gives me a chance to kind of
speak my mind away from the goings-on of
the weekly pool podcast and just kind of
have this you know five ten minutes or
so undisturbed
about you know giving you guys my
opinions on on the this solicitation so
far for speaker wars that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna talk about these
these comics so far now for me i
consider everything that's going on up
to this point to really just kind of be
one big weak issue number one issue
number two the tires all that kind of
stuff i consider this to be one big week
and the reason why is because with issue
number one we saw the end of the
earth-616 continuity and the end of the
ultimate universe and just this I guess
creation of this new battle world and
the reality in which it exists and issue
number two we saw what battle world
looks like in terms of getting the small
tour and then we just kind of got this
jumping-off point you know it seems as
though the race was started and then
with issue number two you know we got
the the firing shot which basically said
everybody can run now and so this is
what we're getting all the solicitations
this is the jumping off point for seeker
wars and so what I want to do here is I
want to start with with the master of
Kung Fu shang-chi and this I think is
really this this story I think this
comic I think there's a long time in
coming and the reason why I say that is
because with shang-chi master of kung fu
he was really just kind of left and like
production hell he was left in
development hell the reason why was
because he actually originates as the
son of foo Manchu and fu-manchu's was a
character that was created by sax Rohmer
in like 1913 or something like that and
and fu-manchu's went on to do it looks
like the archetype for your your evil
asian bad guy basically I hate to kind
of you know make it sound that sound
like it has a negative connotation but
he was the archetype for that so like
you know Emperor Ming from the Flash
Gordon series that was foo Manchu that's
where that character originated from you
know Shan she was supposed to be based
off that but the problem is Marvel lost
the rights to foo man to eventually and
so Shan she just really had no origin
story he was just kind of there
you know we saw that in Civil War for
example they relaunched Heroes for Hire
and they just threw shang-chi and there
it was a huge waste that there was
character into a group like that but
with Secret Wars you know with the whole
battle world thing and Secret Wars I
guess the master of Kung Fu series this
is really cool because now we actually
get a new origin for shang-chi this is
basically Marvel starting all over again
with this character and I'm really
excited to see where they go from here
I'm really interested to see exactly how
they build his character I mean and this
we kind of get the initial starting off
point but this story really kind of
feels disconnected it kind of feels like
it's it's you know Marvel in panic mode
that is to say how can we just take
Shang cheese slam them into a comic and
give him his own story but you know
again I mean I'll give it a chance it's
only issue number one and I think it's
gonna be a three part series so I
imagine this is probably gonna be a
relatively interesting one now one that
I did not find to be wildly interesting
with spider-verse number one now it's
not to say for a lack of trying this was
written by Mike Costa and it was Andre
Oh Roger I think it was how you
pronounce his last name Rogers larcs
really really good here I mean it's what
you'd expect for the launching off of a
premiere title like seeker was number
one as part of battle world but the
writing just wasn't there I mean you
know Kosta was trying to really really
really draw on the whole you know spy
diverse event from that you know that we
had previously seen in bringing these
characters and so basically we get
spider-man India and we get spider twin
but the problem here is a story so
disconnected I mean I know it's designed
to basically set the stage and to say
here's the status quo of the characters
but there's no central villain there's
no central plot here is just to say
sweater Gwen's here and spider-man
India's there and this characters here
and this characters there and so on and
so forth but they're not they're not
coming together for anything and so it
really feels just as disjointed and
spread out and kind of chaotic as the
original spider-verse series but again
misses issue number one and so this is
going to be a self-contained story
it's going to last about three issues I
think and so we have two more issues
let's see the story take form and to see
it become something cool and so again
you know it's it's you really can't say
with an issue number one well this story
is going to suck because there's really
no way to know whether we know what
direction the story's gonna take without
ever actually having read you know the
remainder of what's left so the next one
is ultimate end and the ultimate end I
think is going to be a relatively
pivotal story because what this tells us
is what happened with the ultimate
universe group and the the earth-616
group after the universes ended now it
doesn't give us very much detail all we
really do here is just pick up with the
ultimate universe and the the earth-616
universe both of the Avengers or
versions of the Avengers talking with
one another in Manhattan on battle world
and then of course the Thor course shows
up says doom wants you guys and tries to
take him away but I imagine that as the
series progresses I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be a five-part series but as this
progresses in the way the business is
gonna write it most likely what we're
gonna see here is we're going to see
some event taking place we're gonna find
out what happened between the time of
the universe's ended and between the
time where I guess the point we pick up
were the Avengers from the ultimate
universe and the earth-616 universe of
meet but there's no promises there
because Mendes is notorious for
disregarding continuity and just writing
his own self-sustained stories and to be
truthful I kind of agree with Sal here
when Salas I was mentioning in the and I
think you're in the podcast or something
like that he just kind of looked at this
story I felt like Bendis was just mad
because he wasn't the one writing the
main suger words avenge Jonathan Hickman
was but again you know I mean you really
can't really can't hate too much now the
next one is Deadpool secret Secret Wars
um this story is amazing this is
actually a variant cover I got a whole
bunch of variant covers when I got my I
got my stories there's a one in 25
variants so um I was I immediately had
to jump on this Deadpool secret Secret
Wars is hilarious it is it's everything
that I'd hoped it would be I mean it's
basically Deadpool being thrown back to
the original Secret Wars event and it's
really cool because the way the story
unfolds he's giving us two things at the
same time one he's seems to be present
after the entire original Secret Wars
event is over and he's basically
recouping himself he's reheating all
that kind of good stuff but he's also
telling us how everything seemed to go
to pot and so as the story progresses
which is going to be a three part series
this next part comes out I think in June
and then
July 28 I think is the last issue of
this one or maybe July 20th something
like that but it'll take about three
months for it to finish but basically
it's giving us the run to a rundown on
how everything just kind of went to
pieces and so I'm really cool to see how
the gaps get filled in I'm really
interested to see how everything kind of
comes together again it's gonna be one
of my one of my favorites so the next
one is is a variant for Planet Hulk I
initially would thought about getting
the Scottie young variants but I don't
really like the idea of like kids on the
cover of the of the comic so I was kind
of like no but the the Planet Hulk
variant is I'm sorry the planet Hook
story is really interesting here um
initially and this is kind of the kicker
here we'll talk about this here in a
minute but initially I thought we were
going to see some retelling of the
Planet Hulk event instead all we get
here is basically that the Thor Corps is
traveling along they're going to fly
somewhere I can't what it is and they
basically run into a group of Hulk's and
the way the planet hook is set up the
way the story gives it to us it's
basically this entire territory tire
territory of Greenland which houses all
these different subsets of Hulk's and so
whether they're just being hoaxes
wandering around nomadically or just
kind of you know curious and looking
around like dinosaurs or something like
that there are different classes of
hoaxes there's different societies
groups of hoaxes and so that's actually
really kind of cool here ultimately the
story basically seems to it indicates to
us that Captain America or this version
of Captain America along with devil
dinosaur are basically sent to Planet
Hulk by by dr. doom and dr. strange to
find Bucky Barnes and so I'm kind of
interested to see how this goes on again
this seems to be like it might be
self-contained it might not be with a
problem with this story and well I'm
sorry but we'll get to that here in a
minute in terms of what the problem with
the title of this story is and some of
this other stuff um the next one is a
force and a force was actually a lot
better than I thought it was gonna be
it's set up really really well you know
the idea of having an all-female
Avengers team initially I thought was
gonna be laughable I thought it was
gonna be like Lady liberators I thought
it was gonna be kind of silly not at all
this is a great story the way it's told
so far now again it's issue number one
out of three issues and so as time
progresses we'll of course see how
things turn out but you know having a
team composed of Dazzler having a team
composed of Miss Marvel having a team of
she-hulk which appears to be the leader
of the team you know is really cool
members here but you know again we'll
talk about some of the drawbacks of this
group a force you know as we get towards
the end of this video but you know it's
a solid story it's definitely worth
definitely worth checking out now the
next one is Secret Wars or their mono so
this is issue number one this is the
issue number one variant issue number
two variants did I really get to know a
secret worst battle world okay
so never mind um I was I was kind of
freaking out that maybe I had ordered uh
gotten gotten the wrong ones well we've
done videos on Secret Wars number one
and two so I can go ahead and disregard
those because you know of course I
offered my thoughts on those videos but
you know again at this point that the
Secret Wars event the way it's unfolding
and the way that I think is kind of a
problem here is what Marvel seems to be
doing is relying on knowledge of older
characters and older events to make this
make sense and so for a lot of you who
were sitting down and saying okay
Dazzlers part of this team whose Dazzler
I've heard the name before but I don't
understand why she's here what's her
significance why does it matter the
she's part of a force these are things
that new readers aren't going to know
you know people who sit down and they
look at the title Planet Hulk they say
okay Planet Hulk Secret Wars naturally
they'll look up Planet Hulk online and
they'll run into it and they'll say well
this is a story about the Incredible
Hulk
being sent to battle world you know
being or not about well being sent to a
war world you know I don't understand
how all this ties together and
understand this doesn't make any sense
to me you know that's the kind of
problem that people are gonna run into
and so I think that that you know when
you look at a title like battle world
for example you know Secret Wars battle
world and people say okay Frank castles
soul is somehow tied a Doctor Strange
when they look at that in this say okay
there's another another version of
Wolverine here you know when they look
at things like that they say okay which
version of Wolverine is this why is a
Punisher tied to Doctor Strange I don't
understand what the heck is going on you
know and different things like that and
that's understandable and so what we're
gonna have to do here and we're gonna
make all this makes sense is they're
basically gonna have to explain all this
stuff so I've got a little bit of a
surprise for you guys I know a lot of
you guys have been been really really
asking about a lot of the stories that
are coming up here and so because we're
gonna have to explain these older
stories as we're gonna see them in
Secret Wars of course you already have
Infinity Gauntlet done we already have
Civil War done but because we're gonna
have to explain stories like future
imperfect because we're gonna have to
explain Planet Hulk or World War
I wanted to show you guys the story that
I'm currently working on there's
probably gonna be split into about three
or four parts I'm not gonna swear to
that yet but uh here you go
so that's the one that I'm working on
right now so so yeah I think you guys
are gonna kind of dig that again you
know it's not gonna be like the full
language there's not gonna be the the
Civil War scale discussion is just going
to tell you guys what the finer points
are and what the significance of the Age
of Apocalypse is but the fact remains
here that with regards to the
solicitation a secret war so far I'm
very impressed I'm very very satisfied
here I love what I'm seeing so far
I love the videos that we're getting I'm
sorry the the comics that we're getting
I love the way things are being set up
again the way that Marvel is doing this
here is they're giving us last days
which is the first section they're
giving us war zones and then they're
giving us battle world in truth last
stage probably isn't going to be very
important because last days basically
chronicles the end of a lot of the model
line ups so Black Widow is coming to an
end
Loki agent of Asgard and Vincent I'm
sorry superior I am and stuff like that
that's why you see a lot of these things
going into Secret Wars is because
they're part of the last day's event or
their stories are just being ended or
their characters are kind of being being
brought to an end because Marvel
couldn't simply just stop they couldn't
simply just say okay secret war starts
all these scores are gone they have to
close them out because a lot of these
storylines are still going on for these
individual characters you know that
being said the transition away from
Secret Wars for a second one of the
questions a lot of you guys have been
asking for one of the things you've been
asking for is I guess my my setup my my
whole comic book collection well I'm not
gonna show you guys my whole comic book
collection because a lot of it's in
storage and I don't want somebody like
breaking into my house stealing my stuff
for showing you guys all the comics that
I have but I will show you one of them
and this is probably one of the most
important comics that I have it means a
lot to me one of the oldest comics that
I got but this is Fantastic Four annual
issue number two this is the origin
story of Doctor Doom now in certain
circles is comics worth a lot of money
this is an older comic I mean it's got
some worn edges and different things
like that and so I wouldn't say this
thing is like a 9.2 something it might
be you know in the realm of a 7 or you
know 6 or something like that but it
sold kind of good I've had for a long
time you know and I never really took a
whole you know took really good care of
it because I never thought when I was
younger
I'd be doing what I am now you know and
then I'd be so immersed in the realm of
coming books so you know as a profession
as opposed to just kind of a hobbyist
thing so there you go
it's a fantastic four annual number two
you the origin story of dr. doom came
two years after dr. Doom's initial
appearance and Fantastic Four number
four I think it was so with that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
review to an end let me know in the
comments section whether or not you guys
enjoyed this this kind of thing and if
you do we'll keep this going for for
sicker worse so that being said I will
catch you guys later peace